[Aplausos]
las estrellas son como las personas
todas diferentes sin embargo a distancia
pareciera que todas son iguales
todos tenemos una historia
hoy yo quiero contar la mía
una historia peculiar porque nos hace
creer en los sueños
pero los sueños que son logrados
a través de los años
con persistencia lucha y preparación
para mí es un honor después de 20 años
hablar todo el tiempo de marketing de
redes sociales de estrategias digitales
de eventos de telemarketing por primera
vez hablar de mi experiencia de vida de
mi experiencia personal y quiero
dejarles a cada uno con todas mis
entrañas con todo mi ser con todo mi
corazón esta experiencia que he obtenido
a lo largo de más de 20 años
para mí como profesionista en el área de
tecnología
ha sido un reto romper las barreras el
desafío de las mujeres y la tecnología
uno de los principales mensajes que
quiero dejar hoy a todas las mujeres que
se encuentran aquí es el que tengan
posibilidades de cada día más participar
en empresas de tecnología en empresas
que se dedican hoy por hoy hacer
tecnología porque me pareció muy
interesante una gráfica que les voy a
presentar a continuación
la siguiente es light por favor si me
ayuda
me gustó mucho los niños montan robots
las niñas bailan ballet
a lo largo de los años nos han hecho
creer que las mujeres estamos preparadas
para ciertas actividades pero hoy les
puedo decir con toda la honestidad de
que tenemos el campo abierto para
participar para incursionar también en
la industria de tecnología la tecnología
ha rebasado fronteras podemos
conectarnos desde cualquier lugar en
cualquier sitio y eso super padre es muy
bueno que podamos estar conectados con
todos los seres queridos en cualquier
momento en cualquier ciudad a cualquier
hora
las mujeres sin embargo seguimos
teniendo
varios temas en donde por nuestra mente
cruzan porque no trabajamos en
tecnología aquí hay una gráfica que a mí
me parece muy importante y muy
representativa para que hoy por hoy más
mujeres se convenzan de que la
tecnología también es un sector donde
hay grandes oportunidades para crecer
donde la tecnología existen múltiples
oportunidades para que ustedes puedan
desarrollarse profesionalmente es
mentira que no estemos preparadas que la
tecnología se nos dificulte que no haya
campo laboral que no haya oportunidades
hoy por hoy para trabajar en este sector
que nos cuesta trabajo en aprenderla la
tecnología nos ha rebasado hace poco la
semana pasada lo pudimos ver en el
mundial francia contra croacia si no
hubiera sido porque la tecnología
participó en el momento en donde se
detectó que había un penal contra
croacia no hubiera sucedido en otros
mundiales la tecnología no los hubiera
rebasado sin embargo ahí tienen una
muestra fiel de que la tecnología está
latente
las vidas la tecnología hoy por hoy nos
ocupa espacios inimaginables hace 20
años para el 2020 según según fuente de
iu dc 2020 en dos años todos los
mexicanos al menos vamos a tener dos
dispositivos móviles dos dispositivos
móviles llámese unai watch un ipod un
teléfono celular
la tecnología está impregnada en
nuestras vidas
de ahí que yo las invito las motivo para
que cada día haya más mujeres que
incursionamos en el ámbito laboral en
tecnología hoy el 70% de la gente que
trabaja y labora en empresas de
tecnología son hombres y el empuje el
entusiasmo vamos podemos a trabajar más
mujeres en la industria de tecnología me
gustaría ver en 10 años que en lugar de
tener el 70 por ciento hombres 30 por
ciento mujeres el 90 por ciento seamos
mujeres
ahí las espero nada más me encantaría
que ver más mujeres incursionando en el
ámbito laboral del sector de tecnología
la segunda parte de mi presentación si
avanza por favor quiero la segunda parte
darles los seis pasos que a mí me han
funcionado como maggie bautista que han
hecho hoy por hoy que esos sueños no
sean solamente sueños que los haya
logrado son seis pasos seis claves de
éxito por el profesional personal que a
mí me han funcionado
y que hoy hacen que esté aquí quiero
contarles rápidamente un poquito de mi
vida yo vengo de una familia grande
en donde fuimos siete hermanos yo soy la
hermana de enmedio vengo de una familia
muy numerosa con mucho amor con mucha
pasión por lo que hacíamos eso son las
dos palabras claves que tengo hoy por
hoy en mi vida en mi mente de mis padres
al ser yo la hermana del medio tuvo un
reto muy fuerte en el sentido de que
ninguno de mis hermanos había terminado
la carrera profesional yo tuve la
oportunidad de ser ese parteaguas para
mis hermanos los tres más pequeños yo
estudié en el politécnico nacional
orgullosamente burra
y cuando me acuerdo que hice mi examen
para la vocacional estaba tan nerviosa
que decía dios mío no quiero fallarles a
mis papás si no me logró quedar en la
escuela qué vergüenza en aquel entonces
hace 20 años los resultados salían con
el periódico pues se me tienen un
domingo a las 7 de la mañana
ahí sentada esperando a que llegara el
de los periódicos y comprar el mío yo
dije dios mío yo quiero enterarme
primero de la noticia si es buena o es
mala
yo quiero enterarme y tener el valor de
decirles a mis sopas me quedé sin no me
quedé vio a dole en el alma pero dije ni
modo me tengo que arriesgar más a mí me
tienen formada veo me el periódico y
odios afortunadamente me quedé 88 1300
78 ese fue el número que me dio la clave
para que yo terminara una carrera en el
politécnico llegué a mi casa súper
entusiasmada
mis papás súper orgullosos porque yo
había sido la primera
que se quedaba en una vocacional
ya estudié la vocación al lecce
muchísimas ganas empecé a esforzarme a
trabajar muy fuerte
termino la vocacional me voy a la
universidad terminó en un pizza unidad
profesional interdisciplinaria de
ingeniería y ciencias sociales
administrativas del politécnico estudié
la carrera de licenciatura en la
administración industrial la termino soy
súper contenta primer parteaguas
mi hermana de 21 años fallece de lupus
eritematoso faltando un mes para que
terminara la carrera mismo paso
obviamente me dijeron may y pues no lo
vamos a ir a la graduación tu hermana
acaba de fallecer y lo sentimos mucho
pues obviamente yo me deprimió puse
triste pero dije ánimo may y terminaste
la carrera aunque no haya fiesta de
graduación lo más importante es que
lograse tu objetivo
lograste tu meta que era terminar la
carrera
bueno faltando una semana mis papás me
hablan y me dicen a verme allí queremos
hablar contigo te vamos a dar la noticia
de que si vamos a la graduación ya
pensamos
y es un logro para ti y no te lo vamos a
quitar hija te vamos a apoyar así como
apoyamos a tu hermana que acaba de
fallecer también te vamos a apoyar a ti
así que vamos todos a la graduación
obviamente todos ese día en la
graduación pues con una cara un poco
triste un poco de desencajados por el
momento pero por el otro lado muy
orgullosos de que tenían a su primera
licenciada terminó la graduación y me
voy inmediatamente a hacer mis prácticas
profesionales a una empresa de
tecnología me aceptan me reciben y al
año me contratan muy súper buena noticia
y al año de que entró me dan dentro de
la responsabilidad es un call center de
15 personas yo dije no no he estudiado
liderazgo no no he metido a clases de
moto motivacionales de trabajo en equipo
que voy a hacer pues se me tienen
arriesgarme
arriesgarme y otra vez
es decir tú puedes me lo vas a lograr lo
logré comencé a trabajar con mi equipo
nos fue muy bien al paso de un año nos
dicen que saben que ahora vamos a darle
oportunidad a que el área de
mercadotecnia siga creciendo
me dan la oportunidad de que siga
creciendo y en ese momento decido
realmente tener ya en forma la
mercadotecnia dejo el call center y moya
marketing communication el marketing
communication empieza a ver todas las
iniciativas de mercadotecnia que en
aquel entonces no existía el internet
existía la intranet la telefonía era la
telefonía tradicional no era la que
tenemos hoy digital donde ustedes ya
marcan y ahora que es todo por internet
era todavía de disco era todavía de
botón nos dije bueno vamos a empezar a
hacer marketing generación de demanda
del aquel entonces era mucho a la parte
de correo directo nosotros nos
llegábamos a través de redes sociales no
hacíamos email blas no hacíamos webinar
no sabemos y b&b porque no existía el
internet
empecé duro fuerte y así estuve diez
años y muchas de mis compañeras me
decían my y por qué no asciende es
porque no quieres crecer no no es que no
quiera crecer el momento va a llegar
todo en su momento va a llegar y
efectivamente después de diez años de
trabajar en la industria de tecnología
me llega mi primera oportunidad para
hacer ya
gerente de mercadotecnia me ascienden y
al mes segundo parte de aguas en mi vida
mi mamá falleció de cáncer cáncer en el
pulmón adenocarcinoma moderadamente
diferenciado metastásico primario
pulmonar que que significa cáncer a
mujeres que nunca fumaron el 90 por
ciento del cáncer que se da de pulmón a
las personas que fuman y un 10% a las
que uno fuman
mi mamá le tocó un adenocarcinoma
falleció para mí fue un dolor muy fuerte
sin embargo dije ella ha sido fuente de
inspiración ella ha sido la motivadora
de que yo esté aquí en conjunto con mi
papá así que más adelante vamos a darle
otra vez
asumo la responsabilidad estoy ahí tres
años y oh sorpresa que me da la vida
maggie te vamos a ascender para que sea
la responsable de mercadotecnia para
latinoamérica cinco años viajando por
toda latinoamérica argentina colombia
panamá puerto rico jamaica costa rica
colombia
chile perú
subí a un avión una semana otra en casa
una nueva semana viajaba otra en casa
así pasé cinco años durante esos cinco
años dije llama aquí ya es hora de que
pienses
que realmente
pasado otro paso
dije ok my y cuál va a seguir el
siguiente paso continuar siendo
responsable de mercadotecnia para
latinoamérica o te vas a ir para toda
américa
y ahí fue cuando me puse a recapacitar
un poco y decir el segundo la segunda
clave el esfuerzo
el esfuerzo de ahí que quiero darles el
nombre de cinco personalidades que a mí
más me han marcado y dejado huella en mi
vida profesional
unos josé hernández el astronauta
mexicano
uno de los mejores motivadores que yo he
tenido en mi vida profesional
él fue e hijo es hijo de inmigrantes
mexicanos de michoacán empezó de cero
el hombre aplicó 13 veces a la nasa 13
veces aplicó un examen profesional para
quedarse ahí tuvo que aprender ruso tuvo
que dejar su trabajo formal donde le
pagaban mucho mejor abandonó ese trabajo
cuando lo cuando la tercia da la décima
tercera ocasión aplicó y fue aceptado
ahí él dijo adelante dejó mi trabajo y
se fue ganando la mitad de lo que él
tenía pero se fue a perseguir sus sueños
ese es un caso
otro otro que para mí también me parece
muy muy relevante
fernando landeros el de la fundación del
teletón muchos de ustedes dirán aquí por
es que el teletón si o no
yo soy muestra bien viviente de que los
teletones existen yo tuve la oportunidad
de ir a varios teletones y créanme este
hombre egresado de la ibero con maestría
en harvard en filosofía ha sido uno de
los pioneros en apoyar y creer que los
sueños se pueden hacer realidad en
nuestro país otro otro gran personaje
débora verde bitches
la primer mujer mexicana en cursar un
doctorado en física en stanford con beca
débora tuvo que esforzarse aplicarse
durante dos meses de ocho de la mañana a
ocho de la noche para poder cursar un
año de escuela y que le otorgaran el
doctorado le dijeron te lo damos sin
costo pero siempre y cuando nos
demuestras que tú puedes lo de un año lo
haces en dos meses persistencia esfuerzo
hoy por hoy les puedo decir que no
existen nadie ni nada en el mundo que
les pueda decir que para lograr algo no
tengamos que hacer un esfuerzo
inés sainz periodista presentadora ponle
corazón y determinación a las cosas
tercer punto clave que a mí me ha
funcionado ponle pasión y amor a lo que
haces pasión y amor que estén
impregnados en nuestra piel que cada
momento que queramos hacer algo lo
hagamos con esa pasión cuando la pasión
y el amor en lo que tú haces van
impregnados el éxito aseguró el éxito
les va a llegar solo
otro gran
conferencista y que a mí me ha dejado
también guay a felipe calderón el ex
presidente de méxico
otra mujer que siendo mujer y que para
mí han sido muy muy valiosas es rosario
marín rosario marín quien la identifica
rosario marín ha sido la primera mujer
mexicana en reportarlo a un ex
presidente de eeuu ella fue la ex
tesorera de eeuu en el mandato de george
bush hijo ellas pedían los dólares
ella nos autorizaba otra mujer de gran
perseverancia ella tuvo que cursar
doblemente la carrera en eeuu a los 15
años se va a trabajar con sus papás
sin hablar inglés se pone a trabajar y
estudiar resulta que cuando termina la
carrera en eeuu le dice no es que tú
estuvieses en una escuela que no tiene
validez así que tienes que repetirla
en su historia nos cuenta cómo fue la
entrevista con un ex presidente porque
es fácil llegar con un director con un
subdirector con un chief information
officer con un dueño de una empresa pero
llegar con un presidente a una
entrevista obviamente ella habla de todo
lo que tuvo que pasar pero al final del
día lo mismo logró cumplir sus sueños no
solamente en hacer creer en pensar en
que esos sueños se pueden hacer realidad
ella los implementó los puso en marcha y
los logró
después de que yo ya había decidido
quedarme en standby con la posición en
latinoamérica decido emprender
emprender el vuelo personal nunca dejes
a un lado tus sueños personales nunca
cuarta clave
decido ser mamá y me dicen sabes que
pues no algo pasa en tu organismo que no
no puede ser mamá y yo espero como
porque no no puede ser mamá perfecto me
voy de viaje me fui ese fue el último
viaje que hice de latinoamérica me voy a
colombia regreso
antes de irme a colombia me meto un
tratamiento ya me habían dicho que yo no
podía ser mamá después bueno no está
para mí está de dios que yo no sea mamá
me voy
beto un tratamiento de una muy buena
amiga que me lo recomienda voy con este
ginecólogo y me dice parece que todo va
a estar bien tú tranquila me voy a el
viaje yo súper relajada todavía me
acuerdo que fui a visitar un lugar que
se llama andrés carne de res muy padre
en colombia yo divertida ya llegó a la
ciudad de mexico y me dice el doctor
vete hacer los exámenes
pasamos exámenes y resulta que
efectivamente mai y está embarazada y
aquí siguiendo mis sueños
yo les puedo decir que cuando uno sigue
sus sueños y que realmente los busca los
consigue cuando realmente quieres hacer
algo todo el universo conspira para que
puedas conseguirlo
y aquí mi agradecimiento a todos espero
que algo de lo que está aquí que hice
con tanto amor y con tanta pasión el día
de hoy les haya transmitido vayan por
sus sueños no solamente hay que soñar
los también hay que hacerlos gracias